stormy reminds me she's my twin Kylie
Jenner gets real about her role as
Stormies mom you wanna be a mom someday
yes I can't wait to be a mom even though
I'm 15 I would love that was the now 21
year old mom dreaming about being a
mother years before welcoming her little
bundle of joy
in 2018 and now in a new interview with
Germany's interview magazine
the reality star is revealing how
motherhood has changed her outlook on
life quote the way that I look at things
is a lot more positive and I really feel
like my life didn't start until I had
her Kylie says she wouldn't change one
thing about being a young mom adding she
really comes before me so that is a lot
to take in at a young age but I feel
like I was definitely made for this and
she has changed my life for the better
after stormy I feel like people think
that I like bounce back super fast
especially at such a young age to see
her body go through such a change and it
is physically mentally and emotionally a
challenge since giving birth to her
first child Kylie has been candid about
dealing with her post pregnancy
struggles even Bentinck to big sister
Kim Kardashian about her body
insecurities after a shoot I'm just
feeling a little insecure I feel like my
hips have just spread of no return yeah
Kylie also set the record straight on
the new pregnancy rumor she sparked with
this pic of Kylie and boyfriend Travis
Scott captioned baby number two she
revealed quote I do want more kids but I
do not have any plans in the near future
to have children right now
you gotta do things without me
yeah you know we love seeing stormy and
Kylie bond on social media but will
Kylie's mini-me ever appear on Keeping
Up with the Kardashians Kylie says she's
letting her daughter make that decision
for herself when she is older starting a
company on my own and it being so big
from the beginning there's not a lot of
room for mistakes
Kylie initially got backlash after
Forbes dubbed her the youngest self-made
billionaire ever the lipcott creator
addressed the haters for the first time
in interview telling the mad quote
there's really no other word to use
other than self-made because that is the
truth that is the category that I fall
under I'm the face to my brand and I
take responsibility for everything that
happens the makeup mogul also
acknowledged criticism she received for
being born into a famous family although
I am a special case because before I
started Kylie cosmetics I had a huge
platform and lots of fans I did not get
money from my parents past the age of 15
I used 100% of my own money to start the
company not a dime in my bank account is
inherited and I am very proud of that
she made her own money for over a decade
she put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
when et spoke to the kardashian-jenner
crew back in July they also came to
Kylie's defense I feel like to me
self-made is when you know everyone has
a team
I don't care who you are how you you
know but when you don't get it from
someone else that self-made so it's not
like that was handed to her but the
first time mom has made it known she'd
want to pass down her beauty business to
store me one day Kylie cosmetics
[Music]